in my town
we had a game called the squid game roll
commercial wait is this on netflix what
the [ __ ] do we roll on netflix maybe
roll credits that they'll never let you
watch unless you take the time to find
the resume credits section when the
option should actually be skip credits
and then if i want to watch the [ __ ]
credits i can without being hassled by
algorithms and netflix insane need to
get views counted on people didn't want
to watch but fell asleep or wandered out
of the room so the thing started anyway
and now ridiculous 6 has been viewed 300
million times because people can't just
watch [ __ ] credits and make better
choices with their follow-up selections
also let's address the distractingly
american-sounding squid-shaped elephant
in the room that's our decision to send
the english dubbed version of the show
instead of leaving it in the much better
original korean okay now that that's
addressed on with the sitting it's your
mom your mom if an attacker cuts through
the waste of the squid past the defense
then they are given the freedom to use
both feet what in the name of all that
is calamari are these rules this is a
[ __ ] kid's game whatever happened to
[ __ ] tag you're it
[Music]
man just really leaning into the ip or
ripping off huh why not just give him
the first name of battle and be done
with it if someone on the defense
manages to push you outside of the
squid's boundaries
you die
that's right
you die over exaggerating for dramatic
effect right
right
vanity or bragging take your pick i
sincerely apologize if i'm missing some
well-known south korean subspecies of
this marine animal but on what [ __ ]
planet is this a squid the nose isn't
nearly big enough remember
guyong's birthday is today yeah of
course i do the girl whose birthday it
is is his [ __ ] daughter just thought
that was worth mentioning in case his
reaction to this news understandably
how'd you thinking this person was his
ex-wife or satan please select the
amount you would like
inspector royale did i use it right damn
it ah the old woman cares about her
granddaughter more than her own son and
this is surprising to him in the space
of three minutes he's guilted her into
giving him more of her own money so he
can buy a present for his daughter
harassed her for daring to have a job
and stolen her [ __ ] credit card i
mean what's not to love choosing to show
gambling addiction with people shouting
while watching a horse race only to be
disappointed their sure bet didn't come
through cliche
hey kid you okay finding a hole in his
jacket doesn't immediately mean it was
stolen by this person why couldn't have
just fallen out while he was running
i'm being foreshadowed at aren't i also
there's so little contact here i can't
see how she could have possibly slightly
handed her way into cutting open his
jacket pocket and grabbing that envelope
also also gee whiz she must be the
luckiest pickpocket in south korea she's
just managed to accidentally herself
into a huge amount of cash by simply
being in the way there's no chance she
could have known that he was going to
run through here or bump into her or
which pocket to pick once he did poor
thing
excuse me sir
you need to stop and pick the prize you
want first this kid in the web of lies
he weaves these claw machines were
crafted as a result of a singular never
to be repeated alliance between lady
luck and satan himself their goal was to
create the most efficient way to suck
the soul from a person's body via their
wallet while their disappointed
offspring watch on wishing they had
better parents it's only redeeming
quality is that the second you give up
the next worker that uses it is
immediately rewarded just in case you
thought you'd be able to move on and
live a normal life stop and pick the
prize you want first indeed
[Music]
this [ __ ] picked a mystery black box
when stitch is right [ __ ] there
aggressively hugging a child you do not
know without explicit consent
what's up
huge mosquito bite pencil i had no idea
that mosquitoes even had fists let alone
use them for biting
i know siang isn't going to win any
father of the year awards but why would
he not check what this present is before
handing it over even if it hadn't been a
gun the odds of it being something that
his daughter wouldn't care for are
pretty [ __ ] high it again raises the
question why did he even pick the
mystery box in the first place when
stitch was right there
holy sh did she just pull the trigger
not knowing it was a lighter i'll give
all the sins back if we eventually find
out gaeung is the head of the squid
games hello sir
can i talk to you rumor has it it's
taken this man many many years to
recruit seong into the squid games as a
result of choosing this [ __ ]
approach every day he's had to wait in
this train station for hours at a time
just hoping xiang will finally miss a
train you've got to feel sorry for him
it's time after time xiang would make
his scheduled departure this poor chap
would be left to sadly walk home
shamefully hanging his head thinking no
next time that'll be the time that i get
him just you wait and see i don't
believe in jesus hey you i demand that
you clap your hands right this instant
wait was that for saving jesus or
fairies would you like to play a game
with me agreeing to play a game with
anyone at a subway station at night this
doc she's on for all the some time
[Music]
inspector royal
that's still not right damn it 160
million won owed just to loan sharks
and you owe 250 more to the bank
exchange rates and inflation are wild
man i've spent every other minute
googling juan to dollars trying to work
out just how screwed saeng is the answer
is very to the tune of about 350 000
now i have to sing the show for making
me do math in my leisure time to that in
the remainder of the sins in this video
will be converted to sin won with the
current exchange rate that'll be 1187
sinwon to each usn i rounded down
because the show is pretty great you're
welcome look what i got
[Laughter]
kion what'd you do now
you gamble again don't you look at me
like that didn't compulsive liars he got
into seoul national university thanks to
me i used to take him to school when we
were there's always that one [ __ ]
that manages to ride on the coattails of
the successful and claim that their tiny
contribution was integral to said
success i mean it's not like he created
a youtube channel dedicated to pointing
out the overused cliches and errors in
popular media now that would be a
contribution we're celebrating i got
that with money i made getting slept so
enjoy it thing i said to my parents
after giving them their christmas
presents i bought with the money i made
for my first sex tape somehow makes its
way into the episode who you are
gambling again
of course not it's still too early to
tell if sayong is an [ __ ] or not so
the director told him to shove as much
rice into his mouth as possible just
before he starts talking while the
audience makes up their mind i talked to
that
young man upstairs who knows the law and
he said that
the father
has to show the child will have
financial support and when you can prove
that
then you can take custody but if the
divorce is final and the custody has
already been decreed it'll take a lot
more than extra money to get the custody
overturned did he also suggest planning
heroin on the mother's person because
that would have a better chance of
working or so i've heard i can see why
wanting to keep his daughter would
motivate xiang to try to win this money
but a one-off cash payment isn't going
to convince the courts to give him
custody if anything it's going to look
even more suspicious that this
unemployed man who struggles to keep a
job down suddenly has a bajillion
trillion wand to his name if they're
running this gas every time a new person
gets in the van then the other people
are just getting re-gassed how do they
ensure they aren't bringing any dead
contestants to the game i'd be
questioning the efficiency of this
company immediately after waking up in
this room look at all this unused space
amateurs this entire operation looks
like it's been kitted out with a bunch
of repurposed pac-man and galaga arcade
machines that scar on your neck you're
the damn pickpocket at this point seong
should be well aware that he has had his
clothing and personal belongings taken
and that everyone else seems to be in a
similar position so why does he expect
this woman to still have his money who
the hell
who are you
trying to have a tough guy scene when
everyone is wearing tracksuits
you took all our stuff and put us to
sleep coming here and then you brought
us to this strange warehouse now you're
saying you'll pay us if we go and play a
few games you really expect us to buy
that did this guy not get the same pitch
that cyan got okay the loss of
consciousness and sudden change of
clothing might have been a surprise but
what did you think you were signing up
for if it wasn't this
night school
we do not disclose the faces and
personal information of our staff to any
of the participants except for this guy
in charge of recruitment who has the
most public facing of jobs because that
guy also if anonymity is so important
why go through the risk and effort of
using this recruitment method at all
judging by this crowd there doesn't seem
to be a shortage of desperate people
with debts they can't afford to pay off
doesn't look like there was any need for
this hard sell at all i think most of
these people would have responded to the
business card if it was just posted
through their door with a note attached
saying ring this number for cash this is
now the second occasion of seong signing
a contract with a shady criminal or
criminals makes me wonder why said
criminals are even bothering with said
contracts with contractual consequences
that vary from light maiming to death
surely they can't be legally binding
who'd have loved to be in this designer
meeting what do you think of her styles
and colors well have you ever thought
what m.c escher mixed with duplo blocks
in a little rainbow bright color
aesthetic mixed in would look like
identity verified i actually really like
this show but this sure looks like
they're using facial recognition on a
[ __ ] mask that could be worn by
anybody this could be the dumbest
[ __ ] security measure i've ever seen
and i just rewatched home alone damn
that thing has a freaking huge head of
course it does it's like 20 feet tall it
has a huge everything
well then
then on the first one there talking
while instructions are being given i'm
just saying when your brain sprays out
onto the ground slim shady i'll be sure
to pour 40 ounces if i told you so in
your honor player 324
eliminated why did [ __ ] 324 get the
special treatment of having their
elimination announced when everyone else
in the scene just got mowed down like so
many cannon fodder chatari seriously how
is no one getting caught in friendly
fire here i know most of these people
are down on their luck and probably
don't have anyone in their lives that
would notice their disappearance but out
of the couple hundred dead bodies here
at least some of them have a family
member or friend who would care enough
to call the police in fact the only two
people we know so far definitely have
people who would give a [ __ ] if they
didn't come home and all of them will
have disappeared shortly after having a
strange meeting involving a game with a
person who isn't wearing a [ __ ] mask
i'm just saying how do you cover up this
many people disappearing over a short
space of time all under similar
circumstances without eventually being
found out don't look back just listen
but he literally just moved his head so
how is seong not dead now do the
shooters know he's a main character
we've gone through several rounds of
this game now and i'm [ __ ] staggered
at the dumbasses that are still failing
to follow this very simple red light
rule as if their lives didn't [ __ ]
depend on it
show has time for this automated musical
interlude next time on lost starting
your episode with a visual role
commercials metaphor in your episode
title cliche also that's right we'll
continue totaling up the sins as sin
juan because there's no better way to
prove math sucks than by doing lots of
math plus the current conversion rate is
1166.6
the episode title is hell so it's clear
we're all doing the devil's work today i
don't know if it's their garish color
scheme the whimsical music that
accompanies them or their generally
nonchalant attitude towards death but
these guys always remind me of willy
wonka's oompa-loompas and suddenly this
whole operation makes a lot more sense
to me this is a moody shot and all but
you're telling me that not one of these
remaining participants would still be
screaming or crying or pacing around
searching for an escape even if they
were in shock wouldn't it be more
comfortable to be in shock in your bunk
but no someone was like hey we've got
all these beds and this is a giant room
but let's all huddle silently sitting on
the floor together for maximum downer
vibes cool summer you helped me thank
you no he did not what he did was call
your name which made you turn your head
which should have resulted in your death
although with this show i wouldn't be
surprised if that was the idea all along
we covered this last time but it bears
mentioning again this english dub is
terrible then it doesn't even need to be
there's a huge community of fantastic
voice artists out there you think long
and hard about that while we convert
your 20 tv sins into sin juan i still
need to name my child sir
procrastination also does it make anyone
else uncomfortable that out of the group
of 200 or so people most of which appear
to be men that the first three to beg
for their life are all women i'm just
saying i have demolished everyone in
that room if a grovel contest was the
game reinforced gender stereotypes be
damned
there seems to be a misunderstanding a
misunderstanding of the situation would
have required the participants to have
had said situation fully explained to
them in the first place yes the rules of
the game and the cash prize at the end
of it were all explained but there was
also the very salient omission of being
[ __ ] murdered if you fail why isn't
that in the contract if you just follow
the rules you can leave this place
safely with the prize money we promised
well that's a lie in future games you
also have to win you could absolutely
follow the rules and still be killed and
sure lying to them might make sense but
in a show that seems to be saying the
goal is about order and rules and
legitimate contracts these kinds of
blatant falsifications stand out consent
form clause 3 if all the players agree
to stop playing the games are allowed to
end or am i wrong the contract we saw in
episode one consisted of three very
basic clauses and yet saying woo is
presenting this clause through
revelation as if he's discovered some
fundamental loophole in the magnifying
garda also this piggy bank's on for 35
seconds damn could they not have used
larger denominations also also the piggy
bank makes for a nice motivational
visual but unless they actually intend
on sending the winner out with 45.6
billion won and a few dozen briefcases
what's the point having the cash
physically there is a huge security risk
be they on a deserted island or not and
it appears the pig nostrils are open you
never leave the pig nostrils open
amateurs if you wish to continue playing
press the green button with an o if you
wish to stop playing then please press
the red button with the x instead hold
menus if we stop right now that only
helps the ones who are dead
they get 100 million one and not us
arguments that you think sound really
convincing but simply expose you as the
insensitive and immoral squid that you
really are
we will not condone any kind of act that
impedes this democratic process
therefore any acts we do condone are by
default promoting the democratic process
oink
it seems we're down to the last vote
because of course it came down to the
last [ __ ] vote which means that they
were either all deliberately keeping it
50 50 because none of them wanted to
fully commit to either option or it's
down to dumb luck that they just
happened to be split right down the
middle what would have happened if there
were an even number of players left also
why wasn't this voting in the
accompanying vote counter anonymous
surely being able to see the result in
real time has the potential to skew the
final result come on guys it can't be
that hard to implement a fair voting
system that everyone agrees with oh
oh look there's the form of a stick
figure playing what appears to be tug of
war i'm sure that must mean something
and in a group this size someone will
explore the room enough to find it and
it will result in all sorts of
discoveries can't wait for that to
happen the doctor said there's a
lump inside over here growing every day
brain tumor unnecessary flashback
expositional reminders if the majority
of you wish to participate again
then we will resume the game but how
exactly you send 201 people back out
into the world and then you just wait
for 101 of them to give you a call from
the card do you assume those that voted
to stay will always want to come back so
you just need one person to call what if
a stay vote finds love and stability
outside the game can they change their
vote in the same way someone who wanted
to leave can what if they lose the card
change their phone number how do they
track them this is a fun little twist
but the details on how when and why you
would get all these people back are
vague at best and impossible at worst
but also the choice to put the games on
pause and send them back to their lives
may be the most brilliant part of this
entire show's structure it allows us to
see the driving concept of the games and
then releases us to not only feel more
of the backstories but truly understand
the similarity of their real-life
existence to the game itself it
solidifies the metaphor in such a real
way that i can't help but take off a
couple sin juan for the choice hurry up
now
oh that hurts
hey
hey stop
come on it's my turn now dialogue of my
sex tape i swear i'll forget the whole
thing how can i trust you i swear on my
on my own mother okay this works and yes
we mean it both ways gihon's money boner
is apparently so strong it wouldn't even
wait to allow him to untie his feet so
he wouldn't have to haplessly and
hopelessly hop at the pickpocket
mondays you've got to realize what a
massive deal all this was i know it
sounds crazy it seems like the show
wants us to believe the police never get
involved because of how ridiculous the
whole story sounds but there are 201
people who just left this game at least
a hundred of which were itching to get
out of there they all have cards they
all have eyewitness accounts they might
even be able to describe some of those
who were killed i'm just saying hiding
this game is probably a bit more complex
than no one will believe you so you're
saying that your kidnappers rounded up
hundreds of people and had them play a
game then went out there and shot the
ones who lost previously on squid game
then give us the killer's description
they all had these masks on the whole
time we were there or you could just
describe the guy at the subway station
who definitely wasn't wearing a mask and
is probably still out there recruiting
people but no apparently the show thinks
it's more entertaining for the police to
believe gihan is an idiot so play the
part of the idiot he shall here's the
number it's on a business card call it
and see what they say the one piece of
physical evidence that gihan has and
he's waited until after he's explained
everything in the vaguest way possible
and all the cops think he's actually
insane before he decides to share it
this lidless container and its potential
keyboard ruining contents
it is by no means impossible but it sure
as lucky gihon swings by here right as
sengwu is spying on his mother dumb luck
when you can't be bothered to write
something convincing you haven't been
home in days now
out doing whatever it is you're doing
lately but now you're a good son huh
gihon's mom would be inspector royale at
tv sins remember you ended it and used
up all the cash we had exposition
induced amnesia is just the worse for
everyone a police officer have you
forgotten that is he asking his mom or
us sorry sometimes i can't tell with how
often the show feels the need to remind
us of obvious things we already know
well isn't this the most convenient
episode of conveniences or what chinho
just happens to be at the front desk of
the police station at the perfect time
to notice the squid game business card
being on show so that he'd have a lead
later on when he finds the same business
card in his brother's apartment you just
couldn't write this stuff was he drunk
some crazy hobo guy everything's crazy
around here today unnecessary repeat
sins about unnecessary flashback
expositional reminders abandoning an
occupied stroller someone call teddy
bear protective services let me think
about it
something like sang or song or something
uh
and how about getting me his address too
kihun's name is causing all sorts of
issues but his address no [ __ ]
problem let me just pull it up on my
database i think i have it filed under
moving the plot along it would be
amazing if these episode two moments for
the characters foreshadowed something
for them later in the show i'd take a
cinwon off for that for sure oh well
probably not i imagine getting that to
work would be too much of a pain in the
neck you pull anything on me
i'll rip your [ __ ] throat wide open
and that's that i'm not sure how
effective a throat ripping will be on a
man who can clearly take third degree
burns to 100 of his face as if it were
nothing more than a caffeine-enriched
facial pack
does she keep doing that in this shot
the pocket is completely intact and the
camera doesn't move from her the entire
time she has him in knife point yet now
the pocket has been sliced open and the
contents presumably lifted is she hiding
six extra arms is she this game's actual
squid
[Music]
squid mame i'm afraid that mr chosun wu
has a warrant out for his arrest these
[ __ ] police officers burst into
sangwoo's mother's business while she's
in mid-transaction to accuse her son of
embezzlement and fraud i'm sure they're
desperate to find him but could they not
have just waited 60 seconds for her to
finish up instead of embarrassing her in
front of this customer misunderstanding
the term bathing suit
[Applause]
[Music]
who is it
why did the person at the door ring the
doorbell for all this time if they're
just going to slip the note under the
door anyway why not just ring the bell a
few times slip the card under it and
leave so that i didn't have to be
triggered by the feeling of walking
around soaking wet while fully clothed
wait so everyone's just getting one of
these new cards and they all just show
back up not a single one of these
calamari competitors found something
better in life than going back to the
place that might brutally murder them
sure i send it already once but if the
show's gonna keep complicating this
catch and release and then catch again
program i'm gonna keep on sitting it
i'll continue my chauffeuring and come
help around here this line doesn't lead
to a parasite squid game connected
universe connected universes are the
only true entertainment damn it coming
out to someone's nice pub and smoking
outside's route citation needed what are
the odds you're here at the same time as
me
what are the odds right this is like the
fifth time these two have exclaimed how
crazy it is that they're meeting like
this so i put the odds that show uses
the only random meeting that is
intentional to pound home the
convenience because it makes them look
better later to one something about
friday nights always brings out the
weirdos that's friday nightist parking
in a driving lane on a bridge hey look
here you jerk oh yeah well a jerk is a
tug and a tug is a boat and a boat
floats on water and water is nature and
nature is beautiful so thank you what i
just figured if the show is going with
grade school insults i should go with
grade school come back since and now
you're gonna die your [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the future sir may i recommend exiting
the vehicle of the former gang boss who
you've just admitted to betraying before
prematurely celebrating harder than a 10
year old who doesn't realize that the
t-rex shaped present under the tree is
actually a giraffe they're not the same
mom okay it would be amazing if these
episode 2 moments for the characters
foreshadowed something for them later in
the show i take a sinhoan off for that
for sure oh well i imagine the show will
cross that bridge when it comes to it
you know i watched that guy die with my
own eyes
but no hospital though he couldn't go
honey
we're home judging by this entry the
stepdad and kids somehow apparently
didn't hear any of this borderline
skipworthy ruckus
golf wait it seems that gehan's ex-wife
not only managed to explain the
situation with his mother but also
managed to convince the stepdad to pull
out the equivalent of two thousand
dollars put it in an envelope while
still leaving enough time to catch up to
gihon before he'd barely made it 20
steps out of the building that's some
unbelievable efficiency i mean it it's
literally unbelievable do you think
money sells everything dad why you know
it's not helped by the already mentioned
terrible dub but even without it this
show really does teeter into melodrama
at times maybe they should have named
the show battle royale with cheese
instead of slipping it under the door
like they did at sengwu's place the
squid game [ __ ] decide to leave
gihan's invite sticking out of the door
where it can easily get lost to ruined
by the weather quality my ass cool we
now know why these six all decided to
willingly re-enter the gee hunger games
only 95 more backstories to go for it
all to make sense
zyboc doesn't understand how knockout
gas works and yet this [ __ ] works
probably the most unbelievable part of
this episode is that june hoe follows
the van this closely on deserted roads
and isn't considered suspicious by the
van driver
and that's all i can really say about
that because my phone has auto don't
ruin the plot correct character checks
to see if their gun accidentally
unloaded itself not because they really
need to but because the audience needs
to know they have a gun cliche sure
because sliding beneath a van and
dragging yourself along the road is
super easy to do
[Music]
hey did you hear that
yeah that's the sins bam squid game uses
red text and includes the same bam we
use in our intros and now i can only
assume that the show is taunting us as a
way to make sure we send them so just
remember that anything you don't like
about this video is really the creator's
fault we're just doing their bidding at
this point there are literally drivers
in every vehicle and guards posted for
this very reason and no one sees this so
red suit guy scans the passengers in the
van that he has been driving without
giving a second thought to the reality
of having an additional person in the
back we're not even five minutes in and
we're already dealing with the golden
corral of convenient obliviousness
buffets none of the highly trained
individuals on this ship notice one van
violently shaking back and forth i
should probably just stop mentioning all
the ways people in the show seem to miss
the obvious here's five thousand sin won
for any more instances jung ho change
this guy's clothes then goes the extra
mile to tuck his shirt into his pants
and buckle his belt before chucking him
off the boat just check him off the boat
and stop wasting time murder and yes i
know there's a lot of that on this show
but i think he's supposed to be one of
the good guys for a well-funded
well-guarded death festival this place
sure does have lack security you know
these people are coming back and you
can't invest in a few metal detectors
this very obvious heartbeat in the neck
a lot of people decided to come back so
there you go 187 of the 201 people
decided to come back to murder game
central because when a large group of
people see 56 of their companions get
executed right in front of their eyes 93
of them are like yeah let's go back to
that place think she named
a kid yet why would anyone name their
kid yet you're right who knows what game
they'll have us play next yeah it's not
like they're gonna paint it on the walls
for you come on let me join you guys
geez we're spending the first 15 minutes
of this episode on what teammate
selection just get to the squid gaming
already and satiate our desire for
violence and hypocritical need to send
you for it
how about it
plenty of empty bits emptying stubborn
ketchup bottles on empty beds keep an
eye on the ones who didn't return to
play
and keep me posted me too can i be kept
posted too that sounds like a really
interesting idea and now that you've
drawn attention to it i'm sure the show
will explore it more this season this
may look efficient to you but after 409
gets his foodie crosses in front of 417
which stops the flow of traffic this is
not the vision i wish the rice was
piping hot that's racist and for girls
there's congee elastics cat's cradle
whoa oh there buddy how dare you gender
cat's cradle how pinkie pull your
tractor face so fast you can't even
handle my string theory son this
flapping gum noodle you may be wondering
how anyone would be suspicious of june
hoe in his mask costume but some people
are observant enough to notice that
their neighbor is shorter fatter or
using a different dominant hand all
things that could really blow juno's
cover you know aside from having no clue
about the pink suits patterns of walking
and movement hey hey open the door you
jerks i have to pee really bad right now
this sentence for having to watch player
212 scratch the door like a cat in heat
for 60 seconds so she can have a [ __ ]
potty break also how do they not have a
bathroom open at night in the common
area for the love of prostates are none
of the players over 40. i think i'll go
pee right here and now here i go
you all ready to hear some rain your
intimidation tactics of all the
contraband to slip into the game this is
what you choose to stuff in a container
and pop into your crotch pocket why not
a taser or a knife or don't go back and
smoke whenever you want
are you going to go in there i want to
see what's up there how are these two
not being supervised setting aside that
the powers of the b could certainly find
a female guard it's not exactly like
this place is heavy on the privacy
protocol hey guys make sure you clear
the slaughtered bodies from the floor
and incinerate them oh and strip change
all the players while they're
unconscious but don't you dare be in the
same room as a woman while she pees we
might get sued perpetuating the lie that
an air duct will support a human's body
weight this hurts a lot it's like trying
to push out a kid
ah i'm dying
honest question is she trying to keep
the guard out or get them in here to
check on her because going this far over
the top seems like the latter is the
more likely option
[Music]
i mean this in the nicest way possible
but if 212 doesn't die in this episode i
can't keep watching i just can't the
island
abductions
surveillance
and the masks oh oh things also included
in the show lost please wake up and
prepare for your duties kind wake up
notifications if you want me out of my
warmth cocoon you're gonna have to treat
me like the lazy no good nick i truly am
say something like either get up or i'll
strip your blanket off and squirt you
with this water gun while farting in
your face you know like a good mom would
are you saying they were melting sugar
in there i think they were i know this
clue obviously leads someone to figure
out the next game but why would you
think this was anything more than some
sort of jello or something they were
making for the next meal why is everyone
so sure this is a game clue when if i'd
spotted it i've been like damn it i
found the kitchen but where's the game
closet any chocolate milk i can't drink
the normal kind asking your death camp
counselor for special treatment i'm also
explaining your digestive history to a
stranger as a kid i'm willing to bet you
got spanked a lot
how did you know spanking your children
for being lactose intolerant in other
words parents all the games they've made
us play in here are games that i've
known since i was a young boy and by all
the games do you mean the single game
you've played your theory is fine but
why would you say it this way unless
it's a mistranslation of the dub in
which case i'm more than happy to assign
this end to that nonsense instead you
know as a dub step of precaution where
the hell is this playground so huge i
think it's meant to be a clever way to
make you feel like a kid again but i'm
pretty sure they overshot it by about 15
cause honestly you'd have to be an
infant to be that much smaller than the
slide we can all agree on that right no
fine i'll do the math that slide appears
to be a little over three times as tall
as these guys the average male height is
about five nine so that slide would be
right around 17 feet three inches tall
the average seven year old height is
around four feet and the tallest
playground slides are about 10 feet or
about 2.5 the size of the average 7 year
old which means this slide should be 2.5
times higher than the average five nine
guy or around fourteen four which is
about 35 inches shorter than this slide
and 35 inches over 17 3 which is 207
inches means that this slide should be
16.9 shorter than it currently is boom
math so here's a sin one for the
playground equipment being too large a
sin won for math in general a sin won
for not believing me and a sin one for
all the time you wasted making me do
this
once you've chosen your shape please
stand in front of it
the shapes yes yes that is what she
meant should we play this together that
could be dangerous i know we're setting
up songwood to be a selfish [ __ ] in
this thing but what advantage does he
get by sending his friends and teammates
to more difficult shapes on pure
self-interest alone doesn't it make the
most sense for him to keep them around
at this point he doesn't even have to
let them know he knows what the game is
he can simply answer this question with
a sure let's all be on the same team and
then lead them to the triangle or circle
for some made-up reason maybe like he's
a fan of the netflix reality show the
circle or something synergy songwoo it's
called synergy
[Music]
sugar honeycombs is not a game sugar
honeycombs is a breakfast cereal america
where did all these extra crumbles come
from
one much
how nice that the first player who
breaks their honeycomb shape just
happens to be on the slide and in
perfect position to take a dramatic
tumble down it what a cinematic stroke
of good fortune also we've now entered
the multiple point-blank gun murder
portion of the episode look i like this
show but sometimes i don't like that i
like this show i suppose cheating by
using your vagina lighter as its own sin
but the bigger sin is how do people keep
getting away with this stuff when there
are guards everywhere
number 29. wait is he scamming the suit
we know junhoe hasn't had a chip
installed so are the chips in the suit
that's a terrible idea you know some of
these discount minions are getting
freaky at night and accidentally
swapping suits i hear those triangle
faces are into all sorts of nasty
shenanigans right
i can melt it from the back
the outline is thinner so it'll melt
first yes i know you literally just
showed us that through the actions of
the character you know like you were
supposed to and then you ruined it by
not trusting your audience enough and
over expositioning us we're dumb just
not quite that dumb taking this long to
discover the joys of cookie lingus
well i wanted to send all this close-up
licking so i wondered if there was a
word that better described close-up of
licking so i [ __ ] googled close-up of
licking damn it
[Laughter]
is this show seriously saying that this
tiny needle somehow penetrated that mask
and with enough pinpoint accurate
placement that it's actually in the
guard's eye this needle is barely even
in the mask and that mask is an inch
away from his eyes at least this needle
is an inch away from barely scratching
this guard's cheek at best and i can't
believe the show went with needle attack
for the guard takedown over just
tackling him and grabbing the gun what
kind of sick game was that what sort of
question is this you're literally
playing a game designed to kill people
once again even though i said i'd stop
bringing it up i can't help but say
no one sees this running on the stairs
if these people aren't careful someone's
gonna get hurt
good thing this machine came with the
push the button twice and it will delete
exactly the selection you were thinking
software installed very convenient thank
you thank you for what how am i supposed
to know anything about what's going on
without a previously on segment you
saved me
thank you number one for this graphic
reminder of the events of the last
episode just as my eyeballs had finally
healed from all the acid i had to pour
on them after watching it for myself
thanks a bunch i'm sorry
i was wrong to suggest separating i
don't say that
how could you know what it was one of
the reasons this show grinds my gears is
that i honestly have no idea whether
gihan knows exactly what's going on or
is completely freaking oblivious or is
just outright dumb i really want to root
for the guy i really do i just wish he
wasn't so pathetic once again this
episode persists in piggy banking on for
all of the money grabbing some time the
total prize money accumulated so far is
now 34.8 billion won joe manages to
predict the total number of sin juan it
will get by the end of the season wait
do they not get socks this just seems
like a recipe for foot fungus and all
sorts of unpleasant odors come to think
of it the show doesn't really indicate
if the players have multiple outfits or
if there's a wash day and honestly what
are we even watching for if we aren't
going to explore laundry protocol
hard-boiled eggs would not be my first
choice as a prison manager largely due
to the huge cleanup job that would be
required now since the rest of the
episode isn't punctuated by the
crunching of 200 discarded eggshells
underfoot i'm assuming that somebody
eventually cleaned them all up which is
a huge waste of that somebody's time if
you're committed to eggs then just
de-shell them in the kitchen when will a
tv show do breakfast right when you're
branding their bottles with the shapes
logo what's the point of that did you
have them made up at your local place or
hit up discountdeathmugs.com
i mean if you're looking for marketing
opportunities maybe start with the
jumpsuits
and the director said well they're all
out apples so let's have the character
break an egg on his forehead after
assuming it's hard-boiled so the
audience truly knows he's making an
[ __ ] out of you and um ming why is
212 covering this side of her mouth from
being seen when as far as we can see the
only people who might see her behind her
shut your mouth and grab an egg title of
my sex tape this feels like an extreme
overreaction i mean doc sue is shelling
out a real beating here and if he's not
careful he'll crack a rib and scramble
this guy's poor organs he really should
stop before the yolk goes too far unlike
me the fuchsia suits just let this
beating lead to murder y again up until
now they've been very clear about the
integrity of the games and yes they'll
say they all planned it later but we'll
cross that glass bridge when we come to
it my point is if i was one of the
american vips and i lost a bet on this
kind of off the book i would be furious
i said if you just died
can't you hear me huh
help us now kihan is for some reason
still surprised by the baroness of the
field that should contain the fox given
by the people who run this place this
room apparently has cremation ovens
lined up on both sides it must be hot as
hell in that room those ovens operated
1800 degrees each so at the very least
these guards should be sweating through
their fully enclosed rouge bodysuits
hurry it'll be bedtime too being a dick
about your undercover organ harvester's
bedtime we gotta keep an eye out
it'll be dangerous
and we'll come here if anything goes
down if they're that paranoid then why
are they even splitting up stay together
take a watch each at least then you'll
see the murder coming and have a chance
to make peace with your deity of choice
tonight if anything happens
we'll all meet in my bed right there
are you in lame orgy pickup lines listen
you don't trust people here because you
can
you do it because you don't have anybody
else this could be the worst damn advice
ever given in the history of television
an absence of options does not mean you
default to trusting whoever happens to
be in the room that is not how trust
works people by that logic they should
just go ahead and trust snakes on a pain
in the ass over here and sleep soundly
we gave you less food on purpose to make
you all fight each other first bullsh
there was less food because five people
took seconds sure the portions were
small but if no one cuts in line and no
one gets angry and no one happens to
beat someone to death and none of this
works out to your plan also even if this
is the case which i repeat it is not why
would all the workers know this this is
a triangle face i mean a square face
maybe but a freaking triangle face give
me a break okay last episode they hid
the note in the food because he was in
the middle of all the other players
which makes sense but why bother this
time around they have him performing
organ removals on a corpse in a secret
room and they're worried about passing a
note i'm a doctor out there
you might need me
so
you gonna come give me a shot if i get
sick this show may well be doubling down
on making 212 as annoying as humanly
possible does she need to be this stupid
of course a doctor would be a helpful
addition to the team even if this next
challenge is a zero-sum game of live or
die she knows that they're going to be
starting a fight tonight so what's the
harm in keeping the doctor until then
are you getting any better offers go sit
somewhere in a corner come lights out
don't breathe or make a noise if i hear
you breathe
then i'll come for you turkey basters
[Music]
did that really require a [ __ ] jog
[Music]
this player must have known that she's
in very real danger after pointing the
finger at these guys earlier and yet she
just lays in her bed hoping it will all
blow over you know what they say
denial's not just a character on frasier
also i know i've mentioned it before but
this whole night of murder mini-game
makes zero of the sense as part of the
squid game it depends on random events
and is chaos in an otherwise ordered
environment someone got their purger
butter in my choco squid and i am not
having it also this darks on for all the
some time and then strobes on for all of
the even more amounts of all of the some
time
wow it was almost like they were taking
orders from the random old guy can you
imagine if that was the case of course
there's no way a show about violent
death games would be that nuanced with
its foreshadowing huh
shooting into the air is soon enough
when you're outside let alone inside
where did those bullets hit did they not
ricochet what if you hit the pig won't
anyone think of the pig when and why did
he install interior mask lighting hey
big guy is that a knife in your pocket
or are you just oh never mind
player 277 eliminated player 74
eliminated player 198 eliminated i love
how after drag out melee involving one
knife a broken bottle and a lot of fists
and bunk beds everyone is either
completely fine or completely dead there
should be people with broken limbs
collapsed lungs concussions and all
sorts of various injuries look at this
wide shot i see at least 13 corpses here
many of which appear to have died
instantly from stab wounds and later
they confirmed 27 kills there was one
knife and one broken bottle here in like
five minutes unless john wick snuck into
the room this is an impossible amount of
fatalities show has time to once again
show us how the geometry guards deal
with dead bodies this is the one part of
this that actually already made sense so
move it along people appreciate this
wide shot so i can compare a few numbers
here earlier you said there were 107
people left but there are at least 121
people still lit up on the board here
later you'll confirm the new postmaster
total is but once these lights go out
you're only down to 95. so either you've
screwed up or you've got about 15
nameplates with lights stuck on that you
might want to get checked out got any
electricians in your shapely crew also
why are these numbers all out of order
murder all the people you want but i
will not stand for shoddy visual
organizational practices nobody here got
hurt so that's good disregarding
emotional trauma that's pretty name
i'm not sure how well it fits wow the
rare patronize a woman by calling her
name pretty and insult a woman's
appearance line drive double down the
left field line that's gonna notch two
more sbis and it's only the top of the
fourth sitting but what's my
reward for guessing i'll go think about
it in the restroom okay
well that's escalated quickly previously
212 had to beg to go to the bathroom and
now they're both being allowed out for a
quick hide the squid game of their own
why is this even being allowed storing
your penis and your cigarettes in the
same location who exactly are these
one-word notes supposed to be helping
this seems like june hoe could have
easily remembered so why not add some
more details and if instead their men is
a here's what i learned in case i've
been prematurely cremated message to his
superiors then it's even more useless
this could just as easily be the notes
to junho's debut novel in progress the
story of a triangle mass gang leader
that gets caught up in a riot resulting
in the accidental murder of his own
brother wait someone get netflix on the
line i've got a movie
morse code i'm not sure which to send
more that his brain turned random
coughing into morse code and roughly
zero point get the [ __ ] out of here
seconds or that he happened to know
morse code enough to translate it this
quickly so i'll just send that this
phone still has 39 battery left somehow
instead what's the point of this design
where you have to randomly walk upstairs
just to walk back down them and why are
there no guardrails i'm seriously
starting to think they don't care about
these people's safety we have a team
well the thing is though
so
i can't join unless she does too so
player 69 can't do anything without his
partner being involved nice i'm good at
everything you know that's true how
could he possibly know what she's saying
is true is this a sexual reference
because i doubt that you setting an
intercourse record or being a fellatio
overachiever is going to come into play
in the next game
one
two
three
four
five counting this slow because you're
waiting for the camera to catch up i
would now like to welcome you all
to the third game
today's game is
tug of war episode takes 40 minutes to
start squid gaming this image is
stunning when it comes to cool visuals
squid game truly killer damn it
the us presidency this bloody crucifix
is a bloody lie unless one of the guards
decided to go over it again with a much
thicker application of people inc okay
when i was young we always like talk war
it's a game i know well
and back then
i would always win get to the strategy
already number one your elevator ride to
the death platform is already over and
you're still here giving your bona fides
the show will now slow down their walk
to the rope as if he could give all
these instructions on the way there but
by the time he's talking about having a
good person in the front they're already
being handcuffed in seriously when is
the speech even happening death isn't
the only thing they cheat in this game
they cheat the timing too i'll count to
three
one
two
three is it just me or do these
cliffhangers ring hollow when netflix
has already skip credited me to the next
episode before i've even had a chance to
get up and grab a cup of earl grey also
squid game is bold but it doesn't kill
off 90 of the main cast in one tug bolt
so it's hard to believe there's more
than one possible outcome to this
cliffhanger or is there stay tuned to
the next thrilling installment of tv
sims to find out previously on oh that's
right this is just the exact same scene
from last episode that was cut off right
before i finished i mean it finished so
technically i've already given this
multiple sins but new day new sins also
immediately starting the show with
moaning and screaming so when myself and
everyone sitting around me at starbucks
find out my headphones didn't engage
because the jack is too full of pocket
lint my status is an upstanding member
of society is immediately called into
question and to those of you out there
sneering at the screen and calling me a
luddite for not having bluetooth
headphones the battery and those died so
i was using the backup set of wired
headphones with the accompanying dongle
it was the dongle damn it the dongle
failed me i'm a good person
take three steps when i signal no one on
the other team hears them yelling this
plan out loud
slip-on shoes seem like a great idea
until you find yourself in a life or
death game of tug-of-war on a five-story
high platform breathing breathing
breathing excitement the commitment to
these three shapes has made it all the
way to the controls on these monitors
but why i get the commitment to the
whole theatricality of the game with
regard to the contestants but how does
this help anyone behind the scenes
what's your name huh
what do you care about that
so i can use your name dog number 240
would be the squid game champion at tv
sins even after the dorm when all no
holds barred in the last episode
establishing a severe lack of rules not
a single person takes the opportunity to
push a few of their fellow competitors
off the side of this osha violation
masquerading as a walkway did you see
that guy with his pants like a little
baby making fun of the people you just
murdered what exactly is the point of
the bows on the coffins i mean i get it
stack of the gift box they each receive
but there's no one to appreciate that
decorative decision this just seems like
wasted overhead the success of this body
harvesting scheme is somehow less
believable than the death game going on
upstairs never mind the absurd and ever
expanding number of people that have to
be involved in this plot and all the
infrastructure this process seems to
require the simple fact is it all hinges
on this masked individual recognizing
when this masked individual is looking
at the camera and knowing for sure that
they are the masked individual who is in
on the plan just think of the pileup
that would occur at the bottom of this
incinerator if another unwitting masked
individual just happened to be staring
in the general direction of the camera
for a moment he's not breathing
go get that doctor making me believe for
even one second that they're trying to
help this person from that movie what's
it called matrix hey when you got to
korea is all you did watch movies giving
someone a hard time for answering the
question you literally just asked oh
about that grandma why did you get
kicked out grandma
don't you ever call me that more
importantly why did he call her that
they look to be about the same age it
could be an issue with the dubbing so
i'll just give two sins just so we're
covered what can we do huh
we've got three girls an old man in us
it's like the writers didn't remember
this guy was there when his team won tug
of war against all odds we're all
sinners but we're still here aren't we
the opening dialogue of every tv sin
staff meeting somehow makes its way into
the episode you're not worried at all
those scumbags you got on your side over
there
are they people you trust this is all it
takes for gihan to get under this
asshole's skin a few words about trust
and he has him second guessing his
loyalties it's not like gihan is a jedi
wait is gion a jedi
[Applause]
joe thinks this slow ass double tap
would actually trigger an erase video
footage combo what's your reason for
being
in here the same as you
for money does this question even need
to be asked isn't everyone here because
they need money so in other words joe
has time for this number 29 so you're
finally here the only thing allowing
junhoe to get away with this is an
absurd desire to over tackify everything
why go with this flawed mask scanning
when clearly a password secret handshake
or a polite yet awkward butt cheek grab
would have been more effective also the
scanning happens after they're already
in the room when this is definitely a
situation where you want to have your
accomplices identified beforehand
attempting to wake someone up by choking
them looks like you were having a
nightmare just now he was lying
perfectly still why is question saw game
i saw on the news doctors don't always
perform surgeries sometimes it's the
office managers or nurse's aides why the
[ __ ] is this scene also there's no way
doctors are letting office managers
perform surgeries right right we don't
have time for this being self-aware
doesn't absolve you of your sin in fact
it gets you an extra one
gihan is having flashbacks that we won't
be giving context for until later
directly after a scene where there's
exposition about the doctor helping some
of the squid game workers that we also
have no contacts for and based on what
happens to the doctor in this episode
i'm guessing we'll never have the
contacts needed all this is to say that
this episode is almost 100 filler which
will get you about 12 000 sin won also
this really feels like the show is
trying to retcon this character
mid-season let's not forget this man is
a terrible son and a terrible father
this sequence is making me remember the
mist and damn it i don't like
remembering the mist
no
main character finds out older character
he looks up to a sick and or dying
cliche oh no it's fine i'm fine i nearly
pissed myself that night this transition
it's my fault the zombie was missing a
kidney this single kidney individual
gets the undercover agent disguised as
number 29 thinking he's on the right
path to find his brother because his
brother only had one kidney as well
however this isn't his brother that
they're talking about in fact it's a
female that well we'll see what happens
to her shortly anyways the convenience
involved to have two people randomly
selected for the squid with only one
kidney and then one of them is talked
about right in front of the one person
the story would affect the most is
driving me to drink are you happy now
squid game granted i'm only drinking
lemonade but do you know what all that
sugar can do to a person's body so what
happened
to that zombie what do you think
happened to it june damn near blows his
cover with this question as everyone in
the room goes on to explain that the
person he's pretending to be was there
for the incident the only reason he gets
away with it is that the doctor hangry
and needing a nap flips out and on that
i call bullsh transporting organs in
ziplocks pick up the pace the boat's
already here maybe he's right but how
exactly would he know that they can't
see the boat and no one received a phone
call or a text while they were waiting
for the dock to be finished
his back survives this don't touch it
it's a bomb
they made this passage so the vips could
escape in an emergency since number 28
is assuming for the moment that this is
the real number 29 then why would he
feel the need to feed this exposition to
him the real number 29 would already
know all of this now show me yours title
of my sex tape let's get you washed up
before anything else
show haunts me to believe that seven
people managed to silently enter this
room in the time it took for this guy to
turn around i'm gonna spare you from
having to listen to this man's
description of events all you need to
know is that it starts with necro and
ends with philia and i get the vibe the
show is going for but yuck would we have
done that to a guy
that's where you draw the line now i
give the writers credit for adding
layers to even the minor characters but
when you lead with corp sex homophobia
comes across as a positive attribute
like we should be kind of happy he's not
willing to [ __ ] every corpse do you see
the corner you've painted us into go
check the list if you still don't trust
me i really want to move past this scene
but this just sounds like he's keeping a
list of dead bodies he's not willing to
necromance whether you sell the dead
bodies organs or eat them or whatever
i don't give a damn or whatever like i
don't really want the show to elaborate
but i do but i don't but i kinda do
these people suffered from inequality
and discrimination out in the world
and we're giving them one last chance to
fight fair and win this insight that the
front man isn't just a faceless
administrator and might have motivations
beyond money and mindless killing really
adds depth to the story along with an
interesting social justice question
about fairness in modern society and i
think i like it now take a sinha off
before i change my mind
this episode has so many people being in
places where they don't belong and i'm
starting to believe that no one actually
works here it's kind of like that
episode of unbreakable kimmy schmidt
where we find out cats isn't a real
musical
this [ __ ] just discards this mask on
the ground like someone else is not
going to have to pick it up not going to
show it but it's the old bullet removal
with a knife cliche choosing black walls
for an interior room with no windows
instead of something more light and airy
you know to really open up the space
june ho is in what looks like a very
small document room by himself but
continues looking around with a
flashlight instead of just turning on
the lights if there are cameras in here
this will definitely draw more attention
to your activities and odds are if one
of the henchmen at their arcade game
workstation even noticed this they'd
probably just do the double tap video
erasure move because that's just what
you do when you see a member of the
redman group doing something they
shouldn't three ring binders also why
write the labels on the binders in
english when the rest of its contents
are in korean anyway the writers have
this shadow hide the picture of june
ho's brother because despite the fact
that most people in the show are wearing
masks it's necessary to keep teasing us
with the idea that we might recognize
who he is episode does not contain a
squid game not standing people in
numerical order unless this is some
diagonal bullsh like that player profile
for in which case still bullsh what
should we do
begin the next game i mean what are the
options here watch tiny people do a tiny
performance put smash bros on one of the
screens erase 212 from the very fabric
of time and space was playing the next
game ever really in question what the
[ __ ] is this guy looking at i know the
colors and artistry of the room are
captivating but there's five bodies
hanging there you're trying to figure
out if the walls are tea green or mint
also just a reminder that the game
organizers who had the foresight to
create and install a 50-foot high corpse
mobile in the escher room somehow didn't
know there was an underground organ
harvesting operation going on right
under their noses for weeks through an
impressive feat of fortune slash
fortitude june ho has managed to sneak
onto the island kill a guard replace him
in his job and snuck into the head
honcho's office all without being caught
i could almost believe that if he wasn't
also texting his bestie pictures and
messages that would get this entire
operation shut down on a network that
should be constantly monitored get your
parental controls figured out before
your pink army starts doing all sorts of
shady stuff on there like googling the
phrase pink army this phone rings nine
times if your phone rings more than four
times before letting me leave a message
i'm never speaking to you again
making phone calls what's wrong are you
sad i was but i've quickly moved back to
angry the more over-the-top and cliched
your character gets in fact i've
probably crossed over into vexed if
you're truly wanting to know for this
game you will be playing in teams of two
for an operation that just gave another
big fairness speech i'll just note that
you 100 knew you were eventually putting
them against each other and yet you say
teams of two instead of groups of two
for maximum deceit hypocrites and yes
we're hypocrites too in fact being
hypocrites ourselves makes us hypocrites
for calling you hypocrites and
what was i saying again please look
around and find someone you wish to play
with oh great now i'm having flashbacks
to my childhood all those darting eyes
trying to decide who's going to be their
partner i don't want to be the last pick
i promise i can move as fast as the ball
does pick me please
mom
shake hands to show you have become
partners there can only be two players
per team force monogamy and it was
adam's rip the lord used to make eve
after all
and that's the reason that we're
choosing men 244 and the entire
patriarchy survives this also you've
witnessed hundreds of people murdered by
a 10-foot doll with laser eyes you've
pulled people to the death in a game of
tug-of-war and licked a sugar cookie
until it came to a satisfactory
conclusion dude there is no god you were
someone who looked like they would come
with me title of my sex tape do you
really think you can win without me on
your team rhetorical questions he's a
jerk he's just gonna throw you under the
bus 212 is going off again and no one is
stepping in to stop her for the love of
all that is nuanced and substantial
won't a single writer have a guard tape
or mouse shut or something the lack of
action from these workers is being noted
in my latest escape room yelp review we
are gumbo roll marbles should we do this
to
make it official ah yes the holy pinky
promise the most solid of foundations
for any friendship it's nice to have
such a hopeful and wholesome episode for
once 10 marbles and we can create our
own game as interesting as this choose
your own death venture marble madness is
shouldn't there be some guidance from
the powers of the bee that encourage an
entertaining show for the audience that
may or may not be watching or exist or
not honestly we're five episodes in now
shouldn't the show of at least address
the purpose of all this just a tiny bit
so you guess if i'm holding even a rod
which one you think is in here wait
ollie has never played this game and
you're teaching him the only rule here
is no violence apparently so just tell
ali to give all his marbles to you hide
them around the room then tell them to
count for 29 minutes the first one to
find them all wins you get a one and
enjoy to find wine by now who wouldn't
enjoy a post-murder merlot one of us is
gonna die here so it doesn't matter what
we tell each other no one can really
embarrass themselves anymore no it just
means that you spend your last 10
minutes on earth wallowing in a pit of
embarrassment after admitting to that
time you oh
that was close i almost told you about
that time i swallowed my pet goldfish
and blamed it on the cat damn it i think
he's got dementia does that mean that
he's out or he's not gonna play so that
means he forfeited right even if that
were the case what does gihan think
forfeit means does he think that
discount will riker will be excused from
this game whether gihan realizes it or
not he's trying to convince the guard to
put a bullet in number one's head some
gong boo you turned out to be
[ __ ] god damn it
will you please just pull yourself
together on that thanks squid game for
inspiring me to gronk spike my own
grandmother so she'll finally play call
of duty with me isn't that what i'm
supposed to learn from a scene where
gihan needs marble gandalf into a stone
wall like pizza dough to make him play
games with him sorry i find the lessons
on this show to be a bit elusive
sometimes you people said we're equals
what is this i think we should play a
new game here huh request accepted so
this is when you choose to promote
equality not when it comes to even teams
a fair share of food or preventing a
midnight massacre but rather when a sore
loser wants to change a game to
something he thinks he'll have a better
chance of winning does equality mean
something else in this universe how do
the neon fencers even know when to
intervene are they dispensing order and
justice on their own like some sort of
salmon suited vigilantes everyone wants
to be batman but no one wants to put in
the work to be trapped in a cave full of
bats as a child oh yeah and the parents
murdered an alley thing we take turns
throwing marbles
till you make a shot that lands in the
hole i dug over there i'm pretty good at
getting things in the holes huh if that
was meant to be a sex reference i have
many questions about how this gentleman
approaches coitus none of which i wish
to have answered go to mojito and have a
glass of maldives
really pretending everyone should know
the random movie quotes you drop into
conversation what are you people han
dope
i uh i still have one more there's one
guard per team and all they have to do
is keep track of who runs out of marbles
first and squid guard here couldn't even
manage that if this is his work ethic
then he should try and go look for
another job no
triangle look look i'm doing my best
was that a punch replay that
yep clearly a closed fist with enough
force to move him violence is against
the rules shoot this man guard guard do
they take marble bribes
using two bullets when one could have
done the trick is a modicum of
efficiency per mortality beyond their
accountability damn
your stories are a bit too dark even for
me eli roth which one did you just say
this show man just when i think it's
going to descend into simple battle
royale death matches it delivers the
most heartfelt nuanced morally complex
episode of the bunch centered by this
devastating moment where gehun decides
to lie to an old man to save his life
after having an in-depth conversation
about being bffs it's brilliant but it
destroys me not because i'm weak and sad
about the death and stuff just because
it's so good i have to keep giving back
these damn sin one your pouch there it's
too dangerous to keep it out these
people are bound to go crazy before the
end who knows what'll happen then we
know exactly what will happen then the
guards will step in and shoot anyone
being violent or cheating which ollie
also knows but gives over his marbles
regardless man this show is honestly
great right up until it decides to make
some characters exactly the right amount
of naive for the villain's plan to work
using your mouth to tear the t-shirt
you've been wearing through several days
of murder games without any laundering
service hole in the ground marble drop
marble blowing excitement
this marvelously convenient marble
that blue one that went in that's mine
[ __ ] i mean sure but did you agree
ahead of time about secondary contact
rules everyone here is making the ship
as they go you know because of fairness
and integrity and such here
how's that as it is with marbles so it
is with life ollie ends up dead because
he doesn't take the time to check his
sack stay safe kids and check your sack
regularly
[Music]
at this point the marbles in this bag
have all been switched out for rocks but
when he shakes that bag it makes the
distinctive noise of glass marbles
hitting each other i don't care if it's
in on the foley artist or the show argue
all you want the sin is sound there is
no guard following ali and i just spent
five minutes thinking of a better way
for ollie to use his unguarded time the
finer points are beat up a guard fake
marbles blame shifting more beating a
double-crossing fake trade all ending
with the rose-colored asses duped into
running out of bullets from inefficiency
i realized after assembling a flow chart
and storyboard that i'd rather just move
on and get to the end of this as quickly
as possible why is no one who's losing
in these games just sticking it to their
opponent by refusing to play not a
single person pulled the if i can't win
then neither of us will card let me see
darn it
i'm out of marbles what should i do huh
probably been shot by an overzealous
guard but they only seem to be actively
watching the secondary characters so i
guess you're safe for now and go meet
your mother and then make a whole show
about how it happens you could call it
how i became acquainted with your
maternal parent i bet it's a hit i'm up
i'm honored that the guard gave you this
chance to say your final words instead
of just shooting you immediately like
every other losing player they totally
valued your character moment more than
consistency logic i'd be honored too
what kind of nonsense is this makes no
sense at all direct quotes from a
writer's room argument about the logic
of there only being one battle still
going on and no other panic around the
room in the final minutes of this game
somehow makes it into the episode take
it it's yours anyway i know there was a
little more to it but this match
basically ends the same as the previous
one with one player just throwing it to
the other one couldn't gihan have won it
all in a unique way like jenga or
cribbage or exploding kittens ganbu
always
share everything with each other no
matter what finally an explanation for
the best man's wildly inappropriate
request at my brother's wedding
reception it's okay skip
[Music]
powerful stuff glad the show would never
undercut its impact with a story twist
later can you even imagine oh come on
squid game did you have to start off the
next episode by reminding us that 199 is
gone it was traumatic enough when it
happened the first time i spent so much
time already processing through it in
the 4.8 seconds you gave me before you
fired up the next episode dumb watches
make sure you catch up the vips will
arrive soon show momentarily acts like
the urgency of this matter is predicated
on the arrival of a bunch of jerks that
want bottle service but follows up with
no one frontman included doing anything
differently than they were before so in
the end this was just an fyi to the
viewer you're looking at me like you've
seen a ghost are you okay oh my what a
plot twist did the writers really expect
us to believe a main character is going
to be randomly killed off screen of
course not so it'd only be shocking if
they did i'm giving the show a sin for
teasing such a bizarre exit for this
character and not following through with
it and yes if they'd followed through
with it i'd give it a sin for just being
bizarre welcome to tv sins hope you
enjoy your stay hey this guy knows about
it the weakest link trying to defend
your favorite game show by finding one
other person who's heard of it before
are you in here right now looks like
today's not squid game will be hide and
seek at least that's what i assume
considering the front man is essentially
doing a long-winded version of ready or
not here i come instead of you know just
looking for the intruder without giving
up the clear advantage known as the
element of surprise you made one mistake
i always put the receiver down the other
way running the receiver cord across the
phone you monster also even if it's
intentional i love how the aha got you
measure you put in place is phone
receiver orientation as opposed to
things like security cameras motion
detectors are actual functioning human
guards what's a cop doing here without a
partner how do you know he doesn't have
a partner just because you know he shot
that bullet and someone fell for your
super high-tech phone receiver setup
doesn't mean there couldn't be another
person with him i'm sure you have lots
of questions it's not too late to come
out and talk i can't imagine juho has
many other questions in this moment
aside from why are you trying to have a
conversation with me that being said the
come out and let's have a talk line
frequently used by villains would make a
more compelling scene if people
occasionally took them up on the offer
they actually had a chat and reconciled
their differences but this doesn't
happen it never does stop putting this
in your stories leaving the store and
every other door in this area unlocked
we found a body this call alone coming
in just in time to prevent this showdown
is sinfully convenient but on top of
that a moment ago the front man was so
convinced someone was in here he was
talking to them and all it took to
derail this partially completed search
was a call about finding a singular body
on an island dedicated to murder gaming
where there also happened to be an
unsanctioned organ harvesting scheme
going on in tandem what i'm saying is
their body's literally everywhere but he
assumes they found the droid he's
looking for just because the plot needs
him to also he never says hello or
anything when he picks up the guy on the
other end just starts talking anyway
whether or not walkie-talkies have
evolved to silently notify you when
someone answers this is just bad two-way
radio etiquette over i know i've
mentioned it before but even with more
of the beds missing and this much of
these stick game squid figures showing
not a single person has mentioned the
possibility of maybe looking at the wall
to see which game might be next
making out with your potato also
competing in a winner take all death
game with your friend and or spouse
undeniably makes you an [ __ ] so i can
understand after the last game while the
production team chose potatoes for the
scene there's no reason to guild the
apple blossom but doksu aggressively
eats this egalitarian root fruit to
emphasize that he is the king [ __ ]
and deserves a sin as well and yes i
know that fruit is spelled wrong and
then potato is not a fruit and then i'm
the real king [ __ ]
yummy this is what it looks like when
crabs have been placed on a body by a
set designer in real life they're much
more likely to swim alongside you while
encouraging you to suck face with anyone
who may be accompanying you
[Music]
if a body comes along you must scan it
we found this police id on him which
brings the question why did he put his
id on the guard he killed i mean sure he
probably didn't want to be carrying
around with him in case he was caught
but what's the plus side to having it
found on the corpse just check that
thing off separately you want to start
from the beginning again false
dichotomies
holy sh did you hear the sound that mask
made when he put it down
i'm not even sure how to approach the
science on this one mostly because i
slept through my materials science class
twice and then changed majors but
there's no way anyone would be wearing
this thing for any amount of time i mean
i love the flare but they have to be so
impractically heavy that the only
possible reason these fanciful furry
fetishists could wear these things for
the entire episode is that this sound
was the result of bad communication with
the foley artist
americans oh lord be my shepherd be my
guy this prays on for some time trust me
the screens we have at home are plenty
big but
nothing beats seeing it with your own
eyes oh this is just like in the nba
playoffs where they don't sell the
in-person tickets for the first few
rounds what's that they do sell tickets
to every single nba game weird bringing
in the vips after half the experience is
already over just makes so much sense oh
it's uh such a beautiful number
69. oh you're dirty
you'd think that when the english
speakers came in that maybe the painful
voice acting of the dubbed version would
subside for a bit as we listen to
characters speak with their own voices
you'd think so but you'd be wrong so
very wrong the fact that these colored
platforms for the vips aren't all
circles squares or triangles is an
absolute travesty of consistent design
you made the buttons on the security
camera controls these shapes but for
this you go with what a cloud shape a
cloud
god dammit just tell us about the next
game
how long you're going to string us along
like this half leopard mask [ __ ]
would be excellent at squid game sins
he's in a bad mood because of 69. well
that's just counterintuitive
looks like
a bridge of some sort aside from
revealing that the people behind the
murder olympics are just a bunch of rich
dicks nearly all of the vip dialogue is
just filler to convey their vague
interest in the whole production i wish
the show would just give all these guys
some gold-plated apples and move on to
the bridge to squidobithia game already
please make your way down the steps and
choose one of the mannequins that you
see presented before you once you've
chosen take the corresponding vest i'm
skeptical about whether the process of
choosing the order is actually all that
fair but i'm more annoyed that they're
making the already numbered individuals
choose another number so the sin is
excessive numbering there are plenty of
other variables but i think the order in
which they compete matters most does
position well if i can't do 69
i'll try 96. ah yes the lesser-known
sexual position where partners lay
back-to-back with their butts resting on
the back of each other's necks also
known as the cheeky reiki it's really
popular in certain parts of the florida
panhandle from what i understand there's
16 people left
and there are 16 numbers once again our
hero coming through with the razor sharp
observations the amount of people in
this episode stating obvious things for
our benefit is astonishing i can't tell
if the show is all of the sudden becomes
stupid or just thinks we are but either
way here's your sin not performing the
cheeky reiki correctly they always take
the middle numbers first less than five
minutes ago you saw this setup and had
no clue what this game was but now
you're familiar enough with it to know
what the players always do
okay do it i can't confirm this due to
the fact that they're all wearing animal
masks and that the line was said
off-screen but i'm nearly 100 sure that
was bojack horseman and now i'm upset he
didn't get a bigger role in the show and
now as always i'm choosing my number
last second to last 96 if you were
choosing your number last there'd be no
choice in fact no one chooses their
number last they take their number last
really the person who chooses last is
the one before the final note
i've talked so long i've disproved
myself again haven't i these vests
shouldn't be the same color as the
guard's outfits phew saved it this whole
number selection process accounts for
six minutes of this episode's run time
that's around ten percent i don't even
give my manager ten percent and this
scene is definitely doing less work than
carl oh wow it's bigger title of doctor
who's sex tape also did they think the
contestants were going to play on that
model bridge what is this a squid game
for ants the fifth game is
glass stepping stones all right glass
stepping stones classic children's
playground game good call the tempered
glass stepping stones are strong enough
to hold the weight of two people
however the normal glass will break even
if just one person steps on it don't
worry about the fact that you're all
different weights and that there might
be two smaller people who weigh about
the same as one bigger person the glass
has read the script and knows what to do
have you ever kicked your feet up on a
naked human leopard footstool while
sitting up and forward like this put
strain on your hamstrings and abs the
only reason he's got his leg up there
right now is because the set designer
was like we spent five hours in makeup
on this body pain by golly you're going
to use it mister
[Music]
pain relief that's it
keep
doing that one after the other yes keep
getting lucky just try really hard i saw
a poster once that said luck is what
happens when preparation meets
opportunity so now's your chance also i
think he's well aware he should keep
picking the right one this is like when
someone tells you to drive safe thanks
aunt susan guess the blindfold kane and
ferret idea i had will have to wait for
another day
2 to the power 15
times that
1 in 32 768.
[Music]
i'm surprised no one's intended to make
a run for it oh never mind well at least
i'm going to send the fact that no one
attempts to walk along the red rail sure
it's probably against some rule no one
knows or that they haven't made up yet
and anyone who attempted this would end
up being shot down by a drone carrying
crossbows or some but if any of that's
true we deserve to see it the series
shows us all the deadly details we don't
want for six episodes but now that we've
acclimated to this blood sport they let
up you happen to remember what he chose
next even if she doesn't certainly one
of the other 12 would have been paying
close attention you know what with
everyone's lives on the line and all
right benefits every single person here
for each contestant to get as far as
possible so i'm befuddled as to why this
isn't a more cooperative group
conversation if one of those players
gets scared and starts to run down the
time
we're in danger in the back of the line
true so my question is what happens if
they all die does everyone just go home
do the vips get their money back this is
shoddy game planning at best
there's that sweet sweet squid game
visual flair i know and love take a sin
off for this gorgeous tracking shot
before my goodwill shatters
oh please keon has been diligently
adding up probabilities and tracking the
game and he forgot which one every
single person has been stepping on first
i get the narrative fun of it but i
shall repeat oh please we're in hell
here there's no rules in hell citation
needed
the clock continuity in this episode
isn't great but this section here is
probably the most egregious at the start
of this argument it says 5 46 the show
shows them arguing in real time for
exactly one minute and four seconds and
then shows the clock at 509 having only
ticked down 37 seconds i'm not sure what
technology allows them to fast forward
through time during arguments at double
the speed but market that [ __ ] to
marriage counselors immediately the art
behind them in this room is absolutely
pornographic but it's also kind of
amazing which means they hired an artist
to come out to the hidden death game
bunker and paint the adjoining sex room
i bet that's how they even stated it on
the contract tell me everything
you know about the game i'd give all the
sins back if he started his answer right
now with well it's really one of
fincher's underrated gems
i've accepted the use of these game
pieces to track what's going on in the
game but using them to make the
shittiest instant replay ever well
that's a bridge too far i need you to
know
you've got such a tiny
buying into the line that size is all
that matters it's such a common trope
and at the end of the day it's just a
phallus see now there's a poetic ending
for those two i mean it was until you
felt the need to clumsily comment on it
another student of the bard i had no
idea actually it's not shakespeare it's
congregate william conway the vips take
a break from adding nothing to the
episode just to be kind of okay at bard
since there is no way these binoculars
are doing much good when they have to be
held inches from the face because of
this mask have you ever tried to use
binoculars without holding them right up
against your eyes i mean you can see a
bit but there's no way you're getting a
good look into the neighbor's bedroom
that way i mean squid gaming he can't
see the squid you can't see the squid
gaming i used to make glass for over 30
years uh of course you did the vips and
front man have a quick but boring
discussion about this guy's ability to
distinguish between the different types
of glass and conclude this is not fair
but how is bringing your own life
experiences to the game not fair dukxu
brought all his experiences of being a
big dumb meanie to the game and used
that to his advantage all the time so
how's this really any different i
suppose this could be a point the show
is trying to make saying that they
aren't actually all that concerned with
the fairness of the games but the way
this show goes about conveying this
makes it seem more like the front man
doesn't even understand the concept of
fairness at least that's the only way i
can explain a stump speech in episode 5.
that was in the report
how did i miss that because you didn't
even know what this game was until 15
minutes ago also because you're a lazy
rich bastard who gambles on people's
lives and probably doesn't spend his
time researching every last detail of
the pawns in your game of viscera but
mostly the first thing i see he's given
up on the three button design from
earlier this season and opted for a more
intuitive touch screen quitter okay
standing and admiring your murder
instead of getting the immediate hell
off the death trap i suppose the clock
behind them doesn't even matter anymore
but it was on for most of the game so we
must assume that it's only off now
because it's on the same switch as these
lights at the opposite end of the bridge
and this kind of shoddy craftsmanship is
the reason i have to hit all three
switches in my living room before i find
the right one sharpish explodey glass
mcguffin is cliffhangering all over the
place making it nearly impossible for me
not to immediately watch the next
episode show begins with 26 seconds of
walking and i'm not really interested in
seeing the book of boba fett's squid
game person escaping from bad guys has a
cell phone but can't find a signal
cliche this drawing over here seems to
foreshadow the final game and shows just
two people fighting but how can they
guarantee there only be two people in
the final while still maintaining the
charade of equality in theory everyone
could have survived the previous game if
they were lucky enough why did you do
that is gihon seriously asking this
question i'm not saying yay to murder
but i understand how this game is played
and i'm not sure gihan does how has he
survived this far i don't think
intelligence or skill has played a
factor it's because you always gotta
open your mouth and ask something
idiotic hey leave him alone some of us
make a career out of doing just that
just a dimwit who lives off his mother
but you're with me in this place isn't
that interesting gihon would be the
front man at tv sins why destroy the air
tank i get they've got a boat but that's
a perfectly serviceable air tank that
they could use in the future throw it in
the boat if you don't want him to
retrieve it the date on this phone says
june 29th which makes no sense geon's
daughter's birthday was june 8th and he
went into the squid games the very next
day how's it taking three weeks to get
through five games they had some off
days between games and most importantly
how does the phone still have 12 battery
after three weeks i'll call you again
soon june hoe is proving to be just
another [ __ ] who insists on zoom
meetings when a simple [ __ ] email
will suffice everything he communicated
here would have made more sense by text
especially since that's exactly what he
does next anyway this 30 seconds of
table setting requiring someone to use
multiple utensils for one meal why would
you ever need three forks or three
knives why is this island england
tonight's feast
is prepared as a token of gratitude do
you know what really says thank you a
hot shower and some medical attention to
a mortal wound and to encourage you all
to perform even more splendidly in the
final game because nothing encourages a
person to be entertaining while fighting
to the death for the satisfaction of
creepy millionaires more than a heady
mix of indigestion and exhaustion
he's over there junhoe decides to
inexplicably blow his sizable head start
by standing in clear view for all to see
the plot can only protect you so much
sir no one will be seated as these two
men play a game of staring with stakes
wasting ammo you have him cornered why
is the shot police
put down your weapons you got that
[Laughter]
the coast guard will be here soon i
don't know where the f did you come from
dude i don't even know which way to go
and how did he get here so quickly his
orders were to bring junho to him so why
isn't he chilling on the beach earning
20
you barely get any signal around here
i don't know what you tried to send
but i doubt it went through call me
paranoid but i feel like if i was
running a secret death island of murder
games i'd want slightly more assurance
than barely any signal and i doubt it
went through when talking about the
dissemination of incriminating evidence
one chamber must remain empty and one
must be filled with a blank which means
that there's only
one bullet left in your gun this is
actually true but there's no rule that
says he isn't allowed to carry extra
bullets you know in case he has one of
those fancy guns that aren't single use
one bullet's more than enough to kill
you exactly it's not like juno would be
dumb enough to shoot him in the shoulder
or something
damn it not eating your vegetables i
hear that's the key to a long and
healthy oh never mind who the hell
are you
[Music]
chinho is actually only ten percent as
shocked as he should be considering this
is the actor that was referenced by ji
yong in the gongu episode sorry squid
game if this is like pepper potts
referencing how much she likes rdj in
the sherlock films and you know we'd
send that [ __ ] you know why
valid question why would frontman only
shoot junhoe in the shoulder he clearly
wants him dead so why assume that a
non-lethal bullet wound in the following
fall into the ocean would definitely
result in death now i'm not saying that
i'll give all the sins back if juno
returns in season two but if he does
that's exactly what i'm not saying i
would not do
so this strap we saw earlier was purely
decorative if the goal is to give the
players some tlc and rest before the
final game to encourage them to be as
entertaining as possible why give them a
very valid reason to want to stay up all
night who's gonna be happy to fall
asleep in this situation how is a
three-way fight between sleep-deprived
players going to be entertaining even
worse what if two of them are killed
here and now and the vips never even get
to see the final game this episode is 67
these three staring at each other and
considering the episode is as a whole a
good 15 minutes shorter than the
previous ones that leaves about three
minutes of actual interesting plot
development and by interesting i mean
not interesting at all putting a knife
in your pocket blade up and i would
finally start paying attention thinking
money makes you a good father pulling a
knife out of your pocket handle first
after putting a knife into your pocket
blade up don't do it
that isn't you
you're a good person at heart well
thanks to you we'll never know now will
we because if gihan needs to be reminded
he's a good person to stop him from
stabbing a man in his sleep he's
probably not a good person
[Music]
say back was never going to be a threat
in the final game so wouldn't it make
more sense for songwoo to keep her
around gion would likely take some
stupid risk to protect her that song wu
could take advantage of killing her now
just gives gihan even more reason to get
bloodlusty this sequence slow motions on
for all the some time bafflingly there
isn't a single doctor nurse or talented
butcher that's able to help the front
man with his bullet wound
[Music]
i love you
playing a love song while roasting human
remains over an open fire welcome to the
final game it's the final squid game
[Music]
please choose a shape triangle or square
triangle i feel like gihon should have
been immediately disqualified for
jumping the squid and picking a shape
before being told who gets to pick first
kind of a hero are you gihan i believed
in you
for the final game
you'll both be playing squid game so
this week's squid game is actually squid
game and all the other squid games had
non-squid names but had another game
been named the title of squid game penny
would have been confused by the final
game's name also show called squid game
goes seven episodes without an actual
squid gaming also also roll squid
merchants let me explain the rules of
squid game showri explains the rules of
squid game to us as if we hadn't watched
episode one this morning and were
immediately compelled to binge every
episode all at once once in for not
believing in yourself the attacker must
enter the squid-shaped cord correction
what you meant to say was the attacker
must enter the bauhaus interpretation of
a squid-shaped court
why is he hopping on one foot the
attacker is given a handicap show is
effectively recreating the worst part of
playing any game for the first time
which is learning the rules as you play
because no one bothered to actually read
the instructions the issue is that both
characters do know the rules so this
frustrating experience is being reserved
exclusively for the viewer we always
used to play this as kids despite this
song woo will not see the very obvious
sand in the eyes gambit coming inspector
royale we called it no one would be
better than me searching the internet
and giving up when i find some
unconfirmable explanation that has to do
with magic the gathering if the show
just explained to me why this would be
called inspector royale of all the
things the show over explains for the
sake of the audience this certainly is
not one of them
sounds so romantic what's it mean saying
something sounds romantic without
actually knowing it's romantic because
you don't speak the language this may
not be as bad as the time in paris when
i accidentally thanked the man for
saying some very vulgar things about my
mother but it's still problematic good
dream knows the best time to fall oddly
enough in tv shows and movies the best
time always seems to be during a
dramatic fight to the death especially
when it's written that way she could
have survived they would have treated
her gihan dude where have you been who
in this entire game has received medical
attention when they've required it why
does gihan still believe that there are
people that give a crap about the
well-being of the players even frontman
was forced to dig out a bullet from his
own damn arm
gehan believes that he can kick this
knife far enough away that song won't
possibly be able to ever reach it again
pick up the knife kihan have you ever
been watching a fight to the death and
wished one of the participants would
throw their [ __ ] suit jacket because
that might just be the difference
between losing and winning no me neither
because that would be [ __ ] insane i'm
glad this damp squid fight isn't our
actual climax to the series but it is
the climax to the squid games which i
feel like should be something grander
than this very sad and clumsy fight and
sporadic hopping so many people played
with us but now they're instead of
ending the fight with some quick stabby
stab action song woo feels the need to
take a breather and express his
motivations just long enough for gehan
to muster enough strength to fight back
gehan resorts to being a dirty cheating
ankle biter in this scene so by the
transitive property of slang terms the
sin here is still kids
the camerawork here seems to be taking
on the lofty task of illustrating
quantum superpositions with its own
schrodinger songwoo thought experiment
that is to say until the camera films it
he's in a state of being both alive and
dead and i'm in a state of being both
annoyed and annoyed this game is over
yeah that about wraps it up you'd think
so but somehow we still have 40 minutes
the production team thought that evoking
the depressing feeling when you're the
last one to finish the final exam made
more sense than maintaining a strong
security presence in the wake of an
infiltration that almost uncovered the
whole scheme does he have to take the
pig too it was a dream just think of it
that way and it really wasn't a bad one
for you either okay so i've thought
about it as a dream and i can assure you
it wasn't bad it was horrific and i will
be sleeping with a nightlight for the
next few months who are you who are you
putting on a mask and gassing a person
in lieu of proceeding with an unwanted
conversation this gets us in because
your mouth is the fifth most
uncomfortable place to put a bank card
fourth is your
third is your
second is the
region of your
and right kind of between the
and of course first is a wagon it's been
a few days since she's answered her
phone i should have stopped by to check
on her but i didn't because i'm a
terrible friend hey bro just open your
eyes show has to take out gihon's mom as
well because i wasn't satisfied with the
emotional toll that this episode has
already taken on me if i wasn't so
distraught i'd have considered removing
a sin we've got a real barista working
for us here as opposed to one of those
fake baristas that openly advertise the
fact that they are not a real barista
and he can make you a cup as well i'm
not sure if you'd like it that much
jamie diamond over here is a dick to his
real baristas why am i here what's wrong
gihon is likely one of their most valued
customers in they dragged his ass here
in person without telling why sir if you
want to end up in a deadly life-size
game of shoots and ladders with gihan
betting on your demise this is exactly
how you go about doing it so you see you
created your account here quite a while
ago and and you haven't made that much
effort to contact us since facebook
sending me emails because i stopped
responding to mobile notifications you
see him who billy angel from the netflix
original film's a christmas prince heck
yeah let's go
he must be drunk i mean not necessarily
he could simply be exhausted injured or
bored to unconsciousness by an
increasingly boring finale to a much
bench tv show hard to tell i could
easily snap your neck right here
snapping a neck is a lot harder than it
looks in the movies gihon i've seen you
fighting while you've got some fire in
you i'm not convinced this is something
you could do to completion plus
suffocating this bedridden old man seems
like a much easier option that would
yield the same result and thank you
squid game for once again putting my
browser history on a watch list what
will you bet on with that anything
doesn't matter you might as well take
everything i have it may not matter to
him but the writers think it also
doesn't matter to us i for one think it
would be very interesting to know what
illnom on his deathbed would want if he
wins the bet why did you do something
like this everybody felt that there was
no joy in their lives anymore what could
we all do
to finally have some fun
come on guys you know what it's like you
and your rich friends are bored with
being rich so you think screw it i'm
gonna build a giant murder game complex
on a deserted island hire a bunch of
people dress them in pink overalls give
them a shape-based hierarchy and then
recruit hundreds of people to fight to
the death and jumbo-size children's
games while you watch on and place bets
on the brutality good times you put us
through all of that so you can have fun
it seems that you forgot how no one had
to play ill nom would be number one at
tv since poetic as it may be it is
beyond ridiculous that illnom dies at
the stroke of midnight and the homeless
man is rescued within the same second
gloating over a corpse because i know
that i'm not going to have as much fun
watching us playing show describing the
main reason i don't care about major
league baseball uh what you're getting
done today we're thinking it you're
thinking it we're all thinking it the
red hair is not choice i'm sure it
represents the dawn of a new guihon or
because he's breaking free of the
societal chains that got him into dead
in the squid games to begin with or you
know what maybe the guy just [ __ ]
wanted to leave him b people that's
right this sin goes to you and me for
our built-in biases sir do you know my
sister very well kihan let this kid wait
six months wondering why his sister
wasn't visiting him anymore evidently
gihan's mopey self-loathing was a higher
priority than this kid's well-being this
suitcase full of cash certainly is
dramatic but it's also impractical why
doesn't he give her a check or set up a
bank account and give her a card similar
to the way he was given the money
safeguarding and managing all this
physical cash is definitely going to be
a pain in the ass so gihan is really
being addicted to seongwoo's mom this
disembarks for some time still
disembarking somehow still disembarking
now screw this i'll be back
squid game it's a squid game they're a
murder murder family
all right i'm back oh my goodness
they're still disembarking let's play
again
right now presumably in order to recruit
456 players there has to be more than
one recruiter one of the many reasons
why it's insane that gihan somehow
manages to bump into the very one that
recruited him and at the last possible
moment before he leaves to see his
daughter damn it people we all want a
season two why leave it to chance
whether by chance or design the finale
manages to reflect the entire show a
compelling character-driven story
punctuated with gratuitous and jarring
violence all finished off with a pink
bow of oh my goodness i must watch what
comes next i loved it i think pretty
sure i loved it right but more
importantly does anyone understand how
to play [ __ ] squid game yet
[Music]
i don't understand you
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it i don't believe in jesus
the power of christ compels you the
power of christ compels you
you take the blue pill
the story ends
you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want to believe
you take the red pill
you stay in wonderland
and i show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes
call that number
why
they make your life
fun
that man is playing galaga
thought we wouldn't notice
the first rule of fight club is you do
not talk about fight club
second rule of fight club is
you do not
talk about fight club
look out we're not backing down because
we're the power rangers it's more
morphing time things have certainly
changed around here
i remember when this was all farmland as
far as the eye could see
old man peabody on all of this
he had this crazy idea
about breeding pine trees
you don't know me but
why don't you
i want to play a
i found game
i volunteer as tribute
i'm getting better no you're not you'll
be stone dead in a moment all right as
you wish that day she was amazed to
discover that when he was saying as you
wish
what he meant was i love you
over the hills and far away
teletubbies come to play
get me loose
get me the hell come on get me out of
here come on get me out of here cut me
loose damn it do you have a boyfriend
no
you never told me your name
why do you want to know my name i want
to know who i'm looking at if you want
my mercy
shut that hole in the middle of your
face and listen
don't think i'll go pee right here and
now
if anyone's gonna piss on him it's gonna
be me
in prison dinner was always a big thing
we had a pasta course and then we had a
meal or fish
come on the coast we get together have a
few laughs
the mucus
coating the intestinal wall
spat them
spat them
[Music]
number 29
sir
what's your duty today it's my duty to
please that booty
this is all we get all right now get mad
at them damn days
oh no he died
did you forget the rules seventh rule
fights will go on as long as they have
to
i would like to extend to you an
invitation to the pants party excuse me
the
party the pants with the pants party
with pants brick are you saying that
there's a party in your pants and that
i'm invited
that's it
tell us what are you good at i'm the
doctor
i'm a time lord don't breathe or make a
noise
if i hear you breathe
i'll hurt you down and get you like a
fish
what's your name old man
i'm batman
come on
don't lose your spirit you were meant to
be here tonight
this is your time their time
is done
it's over screw them this is your time
now go out there and take it
get yourself together and listen
i've got you i won't let go
hey you you got a visa
i bet you don't you're an illegal alien
right right somebody said alien she
thought they said illegal aliens signed
up
mr brains you've been captain right
look at me i'm the captain now which
leads me to my second rule
the double tap
how do you expect me to operate with all
of that struggling damn it scotty it's a
rectal examination not an execution it
started glaring at me with one of its
eyes popping out
i saw it in my dream last night he was
surprised
i thought that body was my dead brother
it's okay but that spleen was a spitting
image
whether you saw the dead body's organs
or eat them or whatever
i don't give a damn don't you dare talk
about pineapple on my pizza
ever
you have failed me for the last time
everybody my hp's their pants it's the
coolest
you and me will be the best team
[Laughter]
keep thinking that having men around me
would just make me more powerful but but
i hate men now
[Applause]
precious
sucks to be you nerd you ever have to
see anyone die before this once we had
this play go through my town when i was
a kid as time went on more and more
townsfolk got sick and died soldiers
started carrying the dead into piles and
lit them on fire that's how my grandpa
grandma and older brother all died they
burned together simple yes would have
survived
[Applause]
oh why didn't you just go home that's
your home are you too good for your home
did i say that did i do that
hey
i remember my name now
my name is
my name is
surprise surprise [ __ ] the king
is back
that's amazing isn't it
mania
maniac
we found a body where is it somewhere
under those bushes was the rest of ray
brauer
see that
that's the price of being in here
cost me 14 in a record player i gotta
embrace the marble
hey who were walking
seriously
i find it hard to believe the host would
miss a night like tonight we didn't want
him to know that we were having a game
night you know we used to come and we
just we don't
like him anymore so gentlemen without
much further ado
i give you
[Applause]
the derrick zoolanders center for kids
who can't read good
what is this
but recall too that in the first game
most of the contestants in the back died
after running out of time so i can
clearly not choose the wine in front of
me
what pretty eyes you have to see you
with my
take
your mask
off i'd like to take his his face off
i admire your luck
mister
it's congregate william conway
tempered glass
is made at a heat over 700 degrees pond
on it with a hammer and it rings clearer
than normal
[Music]
so glass blood
oh there's your problem don't wipe
yourself off
you're bleeding
that gun of yours holds five bullets
i know what you're thinking did you fire
six shots or only five well i tell you
the truth and all this excitement
[Music]
[Music]
and do you know what you're gonna do
with all that money once you get out
i'm gonna go to disney world
what happened what
tis but a scratch
we know all about youtube
you don't go in the water like oh dude
some bad hat harry
when you cross do you remember what we
used to call it the royale with jesus
because i was gonna kill you with this
this is like when spock had to fight
kirk on star trek
best friends forced to do battle
[Music]
missed it by that much
he's giving up the prize money right
here at the very edge of victory
oh [ __ ] way i'm surrounded by idiots
what happened what's going on it's like
don't you ever shave of course i got you
a present it's two gifts in one it's a
pen that's also a clock listen carefully
i'm not a cat i'm a person just get on
that plane it's for your own good where
we go from there
is a choice i leave to you
[Music]